oh boy I'm so excited about this donor
party man
why didn't we bring the camera crew Mike
well we're documenting it to show other
donors sort of an inside look at the
campaign of Donald Trump no real
question Mike well we're bringing the
camera crew because we're gonna record
the hot sex that's gonna happen at this
secret society party Bridget this better
be an eyes wide shut party okay cuz I'm
already wearing a condom no whoa wait a
minute what hotdog that's Donald J Trump
straight boy we got a go Mike it's my
stapler I hit the jackpot driver take me
to my State Park
I bought this land to make a golf course
but it turned out to be worthless crap
so I donated it as a write-off oh it's
so beautiful place you've ever seen what
you gotta be kidding me
Donald J Trump sucks State Park that's
impossible you can't suck all State Park
maybe a tree or a lawyer I don't feel
good about this there's a darkness here
some sort of dark presence I'm the
president okay
and the dark one was the last guy come
on let's go get back in the car sir sir
Wow this way Mike so this is more than
you've ever run in your whole life whoa
we are going north always here's Mike I
want to talk about who made it in the
woods
you must have Bridget my log look that
rotten log got a wonderful sir I mean I
did it in the woods one time but I was
alone so I don't think that counts oh my
Moss right there that's my mom that's
great sir my neck guys huh
my neckties
what are they all say made in Moscow oh
that's impossible like everybody knows I
don't have any Russian ties right
Brigitte that's right yes sir
no Russian ties no Russian ties well
let's go look at that tree over there
I own that one too oh and I just farted
I own that fart mic okay what was that
what's the been a sky wolf I don't know
that's not a real thing sir do you even
know where you're going no it's getting
cold and dark sir
oh wow yeah who cares no no no sir look
where we are unbelievable like this is
all your fault for whining is it stupid
compass don't play the compass nag don't
ever blame the comeback sir I know where
we are you two shut up I have a bad
feeling about this hey you listen to me
we're missing out on a killer sex party
which means we now have to have our own
Eyes Wide Shut sex party right here in
the woods are you still in no sir look
sir
look look I don't see anything like okay
Bridget go check it out turn around go
look for it
Oh see what it went on camera see
anything Mike
where the hell the Bridget go Bridget
this is terrible
Mike what we're in one of the greatest
tents ever constructed whoa what is that
who's that
it's whatever that thing is that took
Bridget in the Claudia oh hi Steve Wow
I come here sometimes I build my stone
cairns and perform my rights calling
forth on the ancient power of the earth
and the rock in a pre-dawn tongue no
effect the midterm elections I call on
you I call on you so cool these woods
have power you know there's a monster in
this worth something so dark so
all-encompassing it spends its days
gathering evidence it interviews the
witnesses it thrives on depositions you
know all you have to do to summon this
Muller man mr. Westberg the word
collusion three times
collusion pollution no don't say it
again no no stop no I don't worry I
won't Kalu's no no anywhere he's like
come on let's go sir I know everything
that we did we didn't do anything we
can't we did it all over he's got us
these guys
[Music]
unbelievable
Bridget sir where did you go
it's been like ten minutes get a sundial
bridge it I've been 10 minutes in like
10 hours oh the mother man was so scary
Bridget Bridget whatever driver take me
home
I know where I'm taking you
[Music]
[Applause]